[Music]
hey there folks Chris waters from
GameSpot here on youtubes live stage at
PAX Prime 2015 and we've had an awesome
day of game demos and interviews from
the show what better way to close it out
than with some Guitar Hero live rocking
to close the show out I've got Nathan
from freestyle games here Nathan hey
everyone welcome to the stage placed it
like that guys probably you guys are
familiar with oh yeah we were born in
fish living for the crowd yeah emulating
that experience and especially with
Guitar Hero live you guys are really
bringing that kind of trying to bring
that onstage experience into the game
that's right man we've switched the
perspective now so that instead of
looking up at the crowd and looking up
in the band performing you're on stage
playing out to your crowds of fans and
depending on how well you play if you're
rocking out the crowd are going to react
they're going to be loving you if you're
messing up they're going to be hating
you you know it's like is it gonna
motivate you though or is it just gonna
be like oh man I gotta practice and some
more before I come back in front of this
crowd but that's just one of the ways to
play all right you've got the crowd sort
of that live experience but then you've
also got Guitar Hero TV yes so gh T V
Guitar Hero TVs are always online
playable music video network so 24/7
we've got the official license of music
videos to the tracks and we're going to
be curating different programs just like
TV so you can jump in and play with
everyone else around the world who's
playing the same song at the same time
as you and you've got like different
hours - it's like radio it's like
station program yeah that's right man
you hope you like your rock ow you're in
the yard you can switch between the two
channels and just play along with
everyone else just like a TV shows and
you're playing it of course on the
brand-new guitar this is right we've got
it here for you today to check out yeah
and now this is like it looks like
Guitar Hero guitars have always looks
like you guys have a great craftsmanship
the great kind of weight the series
history does but now it's a big change
because it's not the five buttons along
the neck it's six buttons but they're
stacked yeah so we've done a lot of work
redesigning the controller and listening
to players feedback as well so that's
fed into the new button layout so
there's six buttons one two three four
five six in your two rows so what that
means is that the lower difficulty
it's nice and easy to play just using
one row of buttons no more dangerous use
of your little finger no more losing
your hand moving up and down yeah but at
the higher difficulty level is when you
really want to start to shred you're
using both rows like multiple strings on
a guitar you got power chords crazy
chord shapes to really push the
difficulty as well it can get very
complex but yeah and then like kind of
looks a little like you know I got some
facility with with plastic Rock
I'm sure yeah but you know I you know
looks slide like I've never an expert
player so like the slide is kind of like
alright kind of hanging in there but
when I was playing this a couple weeks
ago
it definitely liked it built nicely and
also I think that the fact that the
complexity is a little bit more like a
natural guitar chord and it's moving the
fingers like this way yeah that's the
you get a bit more of a kind of
offensive connection to the music and it
really helps offer a new challenge for
people that maybe got really good at
previous Guitar Hero games and now want
to try out selling hours learning saying
you yeah and don't get me wrong I played
it for four hours straight and got a
mild hand cramp but like it's just like
when you're learning something new with
your hand you got to train those muscles
but it's really cool and I think we're
gonna play a couple songs right now yeah
let's do it let's jump into the game one
going on to roam along to us while we
talk about some guitar thing and then
we'll go on and maybe I'll join you so
you've got a couple songs here and this
is in the quick play mode so yeah we're
jumping right into quick play now so
when you play G H live the different
tracks are set across to music festivals
that we've created specifically for the
game and you'll be playing in one of our
bands that we've created from the ground
up as well for them for the game so
let's pick out one of these ones and
jump in I'll just show you the basics of
what we've got going on and then we can
play a track together all right
so we're going to jump into Paramore
this is one of the newest songs that
we're showing off this week oh we've got
it on expert mode as well which is
really going to make it struggle during
the talking
so here's one of things to notice right
he's got sit you've got black queues and
white hues for the different rows but
also the pig shaped nose we're a neat
kind of like visual trigger the white
bro is on the bottom the black rose on
the top and the pic points in that
direction that's right so we figured
because we've taken away the row of five
buttons and now it's three into the two
rows the most important information to
get across was the opposite down so we
really redesigned all of the hubs and
the note by way so that it really gets
that information across the players nice
and clearly so neat thing is pretty
excited about I'm doing pretty good at
the moment right which is a bit of a
miracle while I'm talking and playing
but you'll see if I start messing up the
crowd they're gonna flip on me they're
going to change and all of a sudden it's
not going to be such a good story I'm
gonna react I'll be doing an interview
I'm not playing
give me a break come on then okay so if
we pick it up again we could try our
best
going into the chorus we're try and win
them back over getting over hating me on
there now that is definitely the gesture
they would be giving you at a rock
concert there you go pull it back
together
trying and so this is here we go now
we're rocking out playing it up this is
actually expert mode which was a bit of
an actor you're basically playing that's
it so expert is everything that's in the
guitar part of the actual track you're
playing something for in the game here
if I were to pause it and switch it down
to regular this is our default which is
a little bit more easy to handle and
easier to talk and play at the same time
and so the note I always play before
thing yeah yeah so then you don't tape
the new button layouts really introduced
of you gameplay as well so what you're
talking about is bar chords where you're
pressing both buttons on the same fret
moving up and down gives you a different
connection to music if you're playing
chunky power chords and different chord
shapes as well that you get as you go
through the difficulty levels in the
game so that's the basic idea if I'm
playing well the crowds going to react
here we go
the band's going to be behind you and
you're really going to feel like the to
purchase our hero if you're messing up
then you better start playing well
otherwise people are going to be
painting and food
and now in terms of the sort of video
that back here like did this vans gonna
be the band you see every time you play
a Paramore saw this band is one recreate
is just for the game and you'll play
different stage shows we've got ten
bands across all of Guitar Hero live
split between two festivals so you'll be
playing different stage shows with these
bands taking the role of the lead
guitarist so this song Paramore this
band will also play a few other songs as
part of their stage set it won't all be
Paramore songs they'll be other eyes
that you're playing with them as well
very cool and now this is sort of a more
like focus like let's get into it let's
play kind of mode but if you're playing
a mode like TV with the music videos you
can kind of drop in drop out yeah TVs a
lot more about kind of the gaming score
chasing competitive aspects like you've
got Guitar Hero live which is about
making you feel like the rock star up on
stage TV is much more about social
multiplayer playing with other people
online all the time so you can drop in
drop out have a second player come in
whenever you want and it's yet more
about competing against other people
when discovering all the new music
because we're going to have hundreds of
songs at launch
NGH TV running 24/7 in you know curated
programs that we've set up so it's
always going to be something new for you
to get into and enjoy play sounds like
you guys we've got a pretty robust slate
and it's not just for one guitar we've
also got two guitars playable sounds
yeah that's it across both g.h live and
Guitar Hero TV you can play with two
guitars local multiplayer and you can
also plug in a microphone and sing and
you can plug in a microphone you got one
right there
low and behold there's a microphone here
as if I need more microphones here I'm
just like gathering microphones unto my
person that's how I sustain my life
hahaha so can I give the singing a try
yeah let's do it I this is a caveat for
anyone who's watching I'm like pretty
sure I know the song we're gonna choose
I'm strong on the chorus well you did
say you were good at singing heavy metal
songs say I mean claims once made have
to be backed up alright so let's do this
let's get in there I I feel like we
should like stand yeah I think so we've
got a crowd here and we're gonna rock
out we should rock out probably stand up
is that cool I like doing bursting out
there if we suck or we go I want to give
you like we got to both be able to see
this thing
like GM this couch back does this
microphone probably not click when the
game comes live hopefully alright
he's gotta figure out the audio
situation between me actually singing
and me singing the microphone okay I'm
excited this is gonna be fun
yeah alright
cool so we're gonna play gold on the
ceiling yeah I feel strong about the
chorus on that one nice and you know
what folks even if you're not so you
don't know all the lyrics it's still fun
to sing sing along there's a monstery
let's do it here we go so this is set in
front of a slightly bigger crowd than
the track I show you so mean I see them
there you prepared actually looking at
me thumbs down are not allowed on that
YouTube gaming page by the way at PAX
right you ready here we go yeah all
right
[Applause]
- tambourine good get ready
if anybody knows the words feel free to
sing along
[Music]
we and we rockin
here we go they don't wanna get my
am I gonna see them I ain't blind just a
matter of time for his healing it's
alright ain't no God
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
strike
Stangl
they oughta get my
[Applause]
they wanna get my go
on the ceiling I
just a matter of time
oh you're stealing it's alright
ain't no gone
[Music]
they all get
they wanna get my
on the ceiling hi
just a matter of time before you
stealing
it's alright Nino
No
on the ceiling
just a matter
before you steal it
[Music]
it's alright ain't no God my
[Applause]
[Applause]
Goren's ladies and gentlemen it's
possible wonderful
[Music]